it's perhaps one of the biggest
environmental time bombs the world has
ever seen a super oil tanker five years
stranded off the coast of Yemen and
decaying with every passing day the
tanker which you will recall is moored
off the coast of who Dida has had no
maintenance since 2015 and it is at risk
of rupturing or exploding potentially
spilling 1.1 million barrels of oil into
the Red Sea just to give you a sense of
the scale of the problem that is four
times as much as was spilt in the Exxon
Valdez disaster 30 years ago just think
about it 1 million barrels of oil
spilled into the Red Sea this is a
catastrophe no one has ever experienced
before to give you a comparison the
Exxon Valdez disaster 30 years ago
considered to be one of the worst spills
in history had only about a quarter of
as many barrels the Yemeni government
released a video about the extent of the
environmental threat
[Music]
so why hasn't anyone fix the problem
over the past five years
well the Yemen war has put up more than
a few roadblocks the tankers located
right here by the port of Hoda Houthi
rebels control the area and they're more
than willing to make a quick buck on the
tankers oil
we call upon the United Nations and the
Security Council to put in place a
mechanism based on the sale of Yemeni
crude oil including the oil of the
floating tanker in exchange for the
following to provide an import petroleum
diesel and domestic gas is necessary
materials for citizens to resell it to
the banks of Sanaa except they can't
because Saudi Arabia and the US maintain
a sea land and air blockade on Yemen
it's so all-encompassing the UN says the
embargo is contributing to one of the
world's largest famines at the same time
Saudi Arabia is both bombing the Houthi
rebels and oh so generously offering to
tow their potential gold mine away it
comes as little surprise why they'd
refuse you know the two governments are
fighting over the two sides are fighting
over this tanker which has about sixty
million dollars worth of oil on it it's
been stuck there for a number of years
now neither side can agree and and it's
it's a ticking time bomb efforts to
disarm this ticking time bomb are still
at square one the difference now is that
the world won't have another five years
to wait Donald quarter RT
you